I realized that new ageism is everywhere
it's in politics like yeah
well there was that that's obsessed the
new age lady that explicitly New Age
lady Marianne Williamson ran for
president in 2016. she was she was
talking about astral forces and all this
kind of really
specifically New Age lingo on
presidential debate stages yeah that's
insane I think Nancy Pelosi said
something recently about Mother Earth
and how powerful she is yeah
Nancy who who pretends to be a
practicing Catholic though she doesn't
uh accept Church teaching on
non-negotiable yeah Central issues right
it tends to be at least right and I was
thinking in the context of even
abortions because people it's all my
body my choice it's my truth it's mine
there is no right or wrong because I am
the author of what's right or wrong in
my life and in my body and that is
everything that new ageism is about and
transgenderism too right my true self
has nothing to do with objective reality
it's just whatever I say it is and I've
seen how
kind of the culture's obsession
Culture by the way the culture's
obsession with
honestly just
kind of dismantling God's order
like why is that like there's got to be
a reason for that and Hollywood's
obsession with the devil and how Jesus
Christ is The Only Name we blaspheme
people never scream out Buddha when
they're upset you know what I mean like
like it's never that Buddha damn it yeah
exactly no one says that right and no
one gets triggered when you say anything
about Muhammad but the name Jesus Christ
yeah people flinch it's almost like
there's something to it you know what I
mean there are there is a group of
people that gets a little triggered when
you uh say negative things about
Muhammad but broadly in a broad context
it's you know there's there's one above
the mall that is most mocked
um is Saul Kendrick Lamar recently with
the
I I don't think I've ever seen Kendrick
Lamar I saw something on Instagram where
in one of his music videos he's like
walking on water and he's like on a
cross he has a
Crown of Thorns wow yeah or a little Nas
ax he did right the whole video where
he's
basically having sex with the devil and
everyone said people are being extreme
for that but look it's not extreme
because this stuff gets into minds and
it's just a slow drip well there was a
guy he's the deputy monkey pox
coordinator at the White House now
and he's taken photos of himself wearing
leather pentagrams on his chest and
apparently seems to have a pentagram
tattoo on one of his pecs
you have to wonder you say okay if I'm
the crazy one because I'm noticing this
because I'm observing these really weird
specific satanic symbols
that guy's got to be way crazier for
putting it on his body right how come
how come I'm the crazy one for noticing
he's not the crazy one for doing it
right right it also makes me feel better
that even though I thought I was an
alien I was never uh the deputy of
monkey pox
he never won you don't want to be
coordinated
um yeah I it's just everywhere and I
think it's really important to talk
about for that reason and a lot of
people think I'm extreme I lost I lost a
lot of friends when this happened
because
ultimately the common denominator of our
relationship was sin all practicing
divination constantly together whether
it be a moon circle or a Reiki or tarot
cards what's a moon circle
um
so
my obsession with astrology was really
centered around my fascination with the
moon a lot of the time I just
I said in my old Pockets I was enamored
with the Moon
um because the new moon was always
supposed to represent like new
beginnings and setting intentions and
then the full moon was always what I
would say on my podcast the time when
the moon is in its full illumination so
it's kind of shining a light on
everything that's blocking us from our
intentions that we said at the previous
cycle and so now with the full moon we
can release that and so the moon always
falls in it might be a new moon in Aries
and so Aries is supposed to be like the
sign of beginnings and initiation so if
it's a new moon in Aries that's a really
good time to start a new business
adventure so it just always it gave like
a criteria for my life sort of patterns
to follow
um again kind of instilling purpose in
me because I felt like I didn't have any
then just a scheme okay I do this this
month and I do this exactly this is
escapism
um so the moon circles we would gather
me and a group of girlfriends we would
gather every new moon and every full
moon and we would do just that set
intentions or release and this sounds to
me like
witchcraft like a covenant is that what
that essentially we would never call it
that because it's really interesting how
even in the realm of new ageism you
understand that there's negative energy
and negative and demonic influence like
you know why is it that every time we
had to do we did rate gear every time we
did a moon circle every time I practiced
with my crystals or my tarot every time
I did yoga why is it you always have to
pray for protection
why is it you always have to call in an
angel team why is it you always have to
set up
pillars of light around the room like
it's why do you have to prepare yourself
for the worst with all these practices
it's kind of like the same thing with
psychedelics because that's also mind
all altercation right kind of the same
thing and you kind of have to set your
intentions with that too it's all these
things that you have to be really really
particular with you have to follow all
these steps or you could do it wrong
like Sage the room because you know
demons are scared of smudge definitely
uh and for people now who are going to
call you crazy for criticizing all this
stuff people call me crazy for saying
you know actually people do practice
Witchcraft and they say Michael you're
crazy what an insane thing to say
you did it like you did it you saw it
you participated in it it's so again
it's one of these where I go back to why
am I crazy for noticing it
but they're not crazy for doing it
they're actually doing it well the Bible
has the answer to that because because
Satan blinds the minds of unbelievers
and because Satan is the prince of this
world
right and so
you know that's something else that kind
of started to wake me up to
the idea that there is
theistic God specifically the Christian
God
because in 2020 when
um everything went down I was also I was
a seething liberal at the time as well
so I mean it's all connected it really
is because you go to an abortion rally I
guarantee that girl who's naked giving
the middle finger that says F you my
body my choice I guarantee you go into
her bedroom there's a mandala on her
wall like just
what is that by the way it's just like a
the tapestries with like the circles
with all the flowers yeah and it's weird
yeah but I never knew what it was called
they're just like sacred geometry kind
of so it's funny though when you said it
just from the sound of it I thought yeah
okay I kind of get the idea of what and
I'm sure she does because
people try to be conciliatory and nice
and say listen you know a person's
religion has nothing to do with their
politics and you can be uh you can be a
total demon worshiping Pagan you know
conservative and you can be uh Orthodox
Christian uh liberal and but in practice
I've just that just doesn't happen yeah
right yeah
and that's that's what I mean because in
2020 when everything went down I was
obviously had nothing but time on my
hands when I was in quarantine and that
I hit
I hit a rock bottom
um another flirtation with suicide in
that time
but
something that I did with that time was
I started for the first time in my life
began to research things and like this
is when the George Floyd thing happened
to so that kind of sparked something in
me where I was recognizing
inconsistencies
following a lot of Candace Owens at the
time and
um it's actually when I learned about
the daily wire around that time and so I
got curious about things and why the
world is the way it is and what's going
on in the government what's going on in
Hollywood
um oh maybe Trump isn't
crazy mean orange man after all you know
and I got really hungry for the truth
and so I started to be more vocal about
that online like exposing things
as I saw them come up and sharing really
unpopular narratives but true narratives
and that thirst for truth you know I've
always been someone who asks questions
I've always been someone who wants to
know more it's
what led me to self-help I wanted to get
better it's what led me to new ageism I
wanted answers I wanted healing
and my when my politics began to shift
my spirituality did kind of shift as
well where I understood you know
everyone's obsessed with Satan for some
reason like what's that about if Satan
is their Obsession there's got to be a
reason because there's a counter to that
it's actually God and so there's
something there and this is when I began
to understand that there's a spiritual
warfare
so understanding biblical Concepts but
still with the backdrop of Hinduism
where I thought it was just Duality it's
just this state of the universe is good
and evil and it's kind of like a
Battleground for who's going to win you
know is it going to be this
5D Ascension that I talked about earlier
or is it going to be like we just get
worse and worse and worse because the
the evil energy and that's the word I
would use evil energy was winning
whereas the good energy was losing
um because I didn't subscribe to what
the Bible says you know at the time so
I at least began to understand things a
little differently understand that God
was there
and that again truth search I tell
people a lot that if you are hungry for
the truth you're going to land on Jesus
eventually yeah because he's truth right
you can you can go down all these
different paths but you're going to find
inconsistencies everywhere else and
that's all I did for 10 years
I took the long way too you know I was
an atheist for about 10 years atheists
kind of weakened to a sort of agnostic
by the end of that and so I attest to
that a lot of parallels actually too I
mean I never was a part of any you know
covens worshiping the moon or anything
but I got into some pretty weird stuff
and went down weird intellectual paths
and I would say basically it's kind of
13 to 23 that was my real period of
apostasy atheism agnosticism uh it I
remember when my you mentioned your
grandmother dying that was a big moment
when you started to explore these things
I remember my mother died I was 17 years
old and I was so
I I so wanted to talk to her that I
Googled it I said how do you talk to
Deadpool yeah and I knew I know that you
can't talk to dead people or that's what
I thought then
now I wonder if you can talk to dead
people or at the very least you can talk
to Demons masquerading as dead people as
has been attested to throughout all of
human history and but I I started
Googling it and it's it's very tempting
when you're when you're so vulnerable
and you're so desperate for something
you'll you'll reach it anything I mean
you'll go to any kind of crazy length at
all and uh you know I on that particular
path I I never didn't go nearly as far
as you did down it I probably just gave
up after not being able to you know re
your spiritual you know voices and
things like that but you can really get
into some really weird stuff the fact
that you mentioned this obsession with
Satan is so interesting to me because I
I sometimes you'll well if I point out
hey why is that government official
wearing a pentagram
oh Michael that's no big deal it's just
a symbol yeah I think well right but
symbol the whole point of a symbol is
that it symbolizes something right and
so that that's a symbol of the devil
which seems to me to imply
that I that there is such a thing as a
devil or at the very least that this guy
thinks that there's such a thing as the
devil and either way it's pretty weird
that he's wearing that symbol isn't it
and people are just very quick to
write it off just like now you know
there's it's it's seeping into into
schools and into kids curriculums and
even into their play time there's like
yoga Barbies and things like that
and my one friend works at Target and
she was showing me pictures there's it's
like My Little Pony witch thing like you
know cast your spells it just seems it
seems so innocent yeah but it's not and
that's the point and again it's that
Satan masquerades as an angel of Light
it's a deception
[Music]
[Music]